[موسيقى]
بدايه نشكر كل الطاقم الذي استضاف
استضافني في هذه المبادره
التي اعتبرها مبادره شبانيه وقبل ان
اكون مؤسس للجمعيه او كذا فانا طالب الى
الان طالب
جامعي ولكن قبل ان اتي الى هنا بعد ان علم
بعض اصدقائي باني ساشارك في تدكس كجي اش
سي قدموا لكم هديه لاش سي اكس فروم مكاو
فتحيه ل
الصديق سكروم انديا
هذ الثالثه من
يوغندا الرابعه من من
من
نيجيريا
شكرا اذا بهذه التحيه من مختلف دول العالم
وهناك تحيات لم تصل مازال الواتساب و لم
تصل فيسبوك سننتظر وننقلها اليكم ننتقل
مباشره الى البيرو ايضا وصلتني قبل قليل
فقط تحيه اليكم من عاصمه اليرو
لديما از ماي وا هي جمعيه او فريق ليس
جمعيه اسسناها ثلاث طلبه فقط طالب في كليه
الطب وطالب في العلوم الاسلاميه وطالب في
الكيمياء قلنا لماذا نحن الجزائريون
ونستفيد من منحه منحه الطالب ولسنا اغنياء
وانما طلبه لماذا لا نجمع بعض المال من
اجل ان نضع بصمه داخل الوطن وخارج الوطن
فانطلقنا الى
افريقيا لنشهد مثل هذه المشاهد التي
نسجلها لكم من قريه من قرى تنزانيا ايضا
لنرى بعض الاطفال يروا اول مره صورتهم على
الكاميرا وتدخل الابتسامه بسبب اول مره
يروا صورتهم على الكاميرا ولا تنسوا بانهم
شباب جزائريين ذهبوا باموالهم الخاصه
فقط ثالثا يمكن ايضا في بعض الاحيان ان
نمشي في القرى ونلعب معهم كره القدم وفي
بعض الاحيان نبحث عن محل لشراء كره القدم
ولكن لا نجد وانما نجد فقط كره مكونه من
قمش فقط فنلب معهم في بعض الاحيان تجمعنا
معهم بعض الوجبات التي
ا نتبادل فيها الحديث اكثر مما ناكل
فهؤلاء مثلا نقول لكم ماذا اكلتم في قبل
يومين في الغذاء ممكن صعب ان تتذكر ولكن
هؤلاء يتذكرون كل ماكولات لو بعد قبل شهر
قبل شهرين تقوله شش كليت يقوللك هذا هو
لماذا لانهم ياكلون وج واحده على طول
حياتهم بعض الالعاب ايضا في الشوارع نلعب
معهم نجدهم بعض يلعبون في الشوارع ف نلعب
معهم ايضا وبال الاحيان ندخل مدارسهم لنجد
مدرسه فيها مكونه من اخشاب وفيها اكثر من
100 تلميذ بمجرد ان يفرح ويسمع بانك قدمت
من اكثر من 10000 م اليه خصيصا فتزرع
الابتسامه فيه ايضا وجدنا بعض المسلمين
يصلون في مساجد مثل
هذه لا يتمنون شخص اخر ياتيهم من بلد اخر
يتكلم معهم باللغه التي يفهمونها العلم
الجزائري هنا في دوله الم الموزمبيق ايضا
وصلنا الى دوله الموزمبيق ليس الفريق
الوطني فقط يصل الى مثل هذه الدول وانما
يستطيع شباب جزائري امن بفكره يستطيع
الوصول الى هذه الدول هذه في احدى دور
الايتام ايضا اين وصلنا
وقدمنا لهم بعض الفحص الطبيه ولا تخلوا
الرحله من
بعض المغامرات مثل هذه ومغامرات ايضا
اللباس الموحد الذي وجدناه هناك
اليونيفورم لهؤلاء هذا هو اللباس الموحد
عندهم فكل اللباس ممكن ان ترونني بهذه غدا
ساغير ولكن هؤلاء اللباس موحد هو هذا
بيار في افريقيا اعود هذا
هو ثالثا ايضا عندما يدرس ويتعلم هي اكبر
او اقصى حد للسعاده عندما يتعلم
اذا ولكن لماذا يجد صعوبه في التعلم لانه
في بعض
الاحيان يجد نفسه في حرب داخليه فيهرب
ويجد نفسه في ملجا مثل هذا الملجا الذي
زرناه وعملنا فيه في بين حدود بروندي
وتنزانيا الفكره انطلقت من هوري بومدين
سنه 2013 من مطار هوري بومدين حيث انطلقنا
الى الدول التي ترونها الموزنبيق تنزانيا
رواندا بوروندي يوغندا ملاوي كينيا كلنا
وصلنا اليهم ووصلنا العالم الجزائري لهذه
بالتطوع وليس بكره القدم فقط في تنزانيا
مثلا هذه احصاءات كم بقينا في من يوم 36
يوم 45 يوم 28 الى 25 يوم في دول مختلفه
وقدمنا فيها بعض ال العمل التطوعي مثلا
نقسم انفسنا الى مجموعات من اجل الوصول
الى اي منطقه يعجز عليها الناس فنقسم فنم
مشي مسارات مثل هذه فمس مجموعه واحده يصل
في بعض الاحيان الى 5000 او 6000 م في
الرحله الواحده محاور رحلاتنا ماذا نعمل
هناك نجد خدمات تطوعيه زيارات استكشافيه
محاضرات تعليميه دورات تكوينيه وطبعا
جولات سياحيه لاننا وجدنا ما يسمى
بالسياحه التطوعيه في امريكا في اوروبا
ولكن لا يوجد وعي بها هنا في الجزائر
فاردنا ان ننقل هذه الفكره الى بلدنا والى
شبابنا لان الشباب الجزائر كله عنده طاقه
عنده يسافر ولكن لابد ان يسافر من اجل ان
يضع بصمه هناك اهم ميدين العمل هي التعليم
هي الاغاثه هي الصحه التعليم هو اهم مجال
لماذا لانه افريقيا لو نبقى نعطيها 500
سنه 600 سنه ياكلون ويشربون فلن يتغيروا
اعطيكم قصه وقعت لنا من القصص الكثيره جدا
التي وقعت لنا انه وجدنا فلاح اعطته
الحكومه قطعه ارض كبيره جدا من اجل ان
يزرع وياكل هو وعائلته و
يستثمر في الفلاحه ويصبح غني ولكن بعد ست
اشهر نعود اليه فنجده بانه استثمر وزرع حق
ما ياكل هو وعائلته فقط ففهمنا ان المشكل
موجود في الذهنيه وليس المشكل في الثروات
الاماكن التي عملنا فيها دور الايتام
الاورنج المدارس المستشفيات القرى والجزر
والارياف وبما اننا دخلنا الى هذه القرى
التي لا يتقن اهلها اللغه الانجليزيه فلا
بد ان نتعلم لغتهم مثل اللغه السواحليه
فانا اتقن اللغه السواحليه لمن اراد ان
يتحدث معي فيما بعد فاقول لكم كريبو سانا
كتيكا تدكس اش سي
الجي معناها معناها مرحبا بكم في
تدكس محور التعليم مثلا وجدنا بعض الاطفال
يخرجون صباحا على الثامنه صباحا ينطلقون
بدلو عنده دلو بدون ينطلق صباحا ليصل الى
اقرب بئر بعد مده مده زمنيه ثم يعود بحمل
اثقل يعني بعد ما يعمر الماء يجي بحمل
اثقل يصل على الثالثه مساء الرابعه مساء
هل هذا سيلقى فرصه للتعليم او للتعلم ابدا
اذا ماذا نقوم نحن بمجهودات بسيطه نحاول
ان نحفر له بئر فنوفر له الماء ونوفر له
التعليم
ا هذا الفصل مثلا هذا الفصل ونحن في
اوغندا كما تعرفون انه غندا تروبيكال
سيزون معروفه بالمناخ الاستوائي فيه امطار
كثيره جدا فيوم من الايام غلبتنا الامطار
فاردنا ان ندخل فوجدنا كوخ بمجرد ان دخلنا
الى ذلك الكوخ اكتشفنا بان امام سبوره
وامام الواح في الارض وهي بركه مائيه
فقلنا هذه هل هي هذه مدرستكم قالوا نعم هي
مدرستنا ولكن اذا كنت انتم في الجزائر
عندكم العطله والاجازه في ديسمبر في مارس
في الصيف نحن كلما تحت المطر عندنا اجازه
لان مدارسنا تتحول الى برك مائيه هذا
النوع من المدارس ايضا نجده في المناطق
التي زرناها التلاميذ هنا في امتحان ههم
في امتحان يا امتحان رسمي ايضا فنلاحظ
واقعهم ايضا ايضا نجد بعضهم خاصه من
المسلمين يفرح اذا اذا علمته كلمه باللغه
العربيه فيقفون انا في الشوارع في كذا في
اي مكان يقول لك
بيزوك من فضلك ماه ماذا تقولون المسجد
بالعربيه فيقول مسجد لانه مسلم لا يعرف ما
معنى المسجد ببساطه انه اذا انتم استوردنا
مثلا استوردنا اي اي منتوج من الصين
فالكتالوج اذا كان باللغه الصينيه فنسبه
الذي يفهمون الكتالوج صعبه جدا يعني قليله
جدا ممكن 1% من هذا القاع يفهم اللغه
الصينيه او اكثر لا اعرف ولكن هؤلاء
مسلمون عندما يفتح المصحف الكريم يرى
اللغه العربيه مثل ما ترى انت او ترين انت
اللغه الصينيه
ا هذا ايضا في معنى في الفريق ايضا من هو
مختص في الطاقات الشمسيه لاننا نعمل في
الطاقه الشمسيه هناك ولكن عنده هوايات
اخرى مثل هذا الصديق موسى الذي يعمل ايضا
في هذا تبهج الاطفال هناك ما نقدم ايضا
عندما نذهب الى القرى والجزر البعيده
نختار النوابغ منهم ونمنحهم منح دراسيه
لينتقلوا الى اقرب مدرسه وجدنا فيها
المعايير التي
ا رشحتها لان تكون رائده فنن قلهم الى
هناك و ندفع لهم منحه ل حوالي سبع سنوات
او ثمان سنوات ليعود الى قريته ليعلمهم
واو يصبح طبيبا او الى
اخره دائما لا ننسى نحن طلبه جزائريون
انطلقنا من جامعه الجزائريه ووصلنا الى
هنا هنا فقط باراده فقط المدارس ايضا بعض
المدارس تحتاج في بعض المدارس مثلا هناك
ممكن الجزائر بع المناطق الداخليه في
الجزائر في سنه الاربعينيات الخمسينيات
ماكش تري سيتي فبم بوصول المغرب ونزول
الشمس فخلاص يعني خلاص الضوء ماكاش
الكهرباء هناك ايضا مناطق تنتهي الكهرباء
على ساعه بعد بغروب الشمس ولكن نجد بعض
الشباب يريد ان يعلم الناس الاطفال الصغار
صباحا والكبار والنساء مساء في الليل
فماذا نعمل بالطاقه الشمسيه نوفر لهم
الكهرباء من اجل ان يتعلموا في الليل هذه
كانت هكذا من بين المدارس التي زرناها
كانت هكذا قبل قبل شهور فقط
واصبحت
هكذا هناك مدارس ايضا طور البناء في 2016
هذه ايضا كلها كانت مثل التي رايتموها
كلها كانت مثل هذه والان الحمد لله الان
في طور الانجاز هذه في طور الانجاز هذه
الصوره الاخيره لنفهم بان هذا ليس غني ولا
مستثمر دعم هذه وانما ثانويه من الثانويات
الجزائريه عندما شرحنا لهم المشروع الطلبه
قالوا نريد ان نبني مدرسه لاخواننا هناك
فجمعوا كل التبرعات كلهم جمعوا 5000 10000
100000 500 ال فجمعنا تبرع فبينا به هذه
المدرسه الاخيره التي ترونها التعليم هو
الحل كما قلت بانه كل شيء لن يتغير في
افريقيا الا بالتعليم هذه اهم الاشياء
التي قمنا بها مثل توزيع المقررات
الدراسيه نجد بعض المدارس موجوده ولكن ليس
لديه مقررات ناخذ معنا بعض المقررات
الجزائريه ونشتري بعض المقررات من هناك
دراسيه لنصل بها
الى القرى والجزر النائيه البعيده ايضا
الاساتذه الذي يهربون يقول لك انا لا
اواصل في هذه الجزيره وهو الوحيد في تلك
الجزيره يقوللك لابد ان اهرب عندي ابناء
ويعطوني 300000 ولا 400000 تاع الجزائر
فنقول له ابقى هناك اذا اعطوا لك 30000000
نحن نعطيك مليون ونص بقيمه الجزائر ومليون
ونص هناك قيمه كبيره جدا في الشهر فيبقى
لمده سنه يتعلم هؤلاء ابناء
القريه محور الاغاثه ثانيا وهو هنا من هنا
يشرب هؤلاء
هؤلاء الابناء وهناك ايضا مناطق كثيره
يشربون فوجدنا بان الماء هي معاناه يوميه
ستقولون منطقه استوائيه ولكن ليس لديه ماء
ف دائما يفهم بان المشكل في الذهنيه وليس
في الثروات اريد ان اشرب ماء هذه من الصور
التي ونجدها في طرقنا اليوميه هناك في
افريقيا ايضا بعض المناطق لا تستطيع ان
تعلمه قبل ان ياكل وقبل ان يشرب اعرفكم
بشخص اسمه عبد الرحمن سميت هو دكتور طبيب
كويتي درس في كندا ودرس في بريطانيا ولكن
قرر ان يعود الى افريقيا من اجل ان يعمل
زار قريه من القرى فوجد عائله لم تاكل
لمده ثلاث ايام فقدم لهم وجبه قال لهم لا
لا تقدم لا تقدم لنا هذه الوجبه وانما
هناك عائله بجيرانه لم ياكلوا منذ ست
ايام ابتسامه لا تغادر محياهم هذه في
شوارع الموزنبيق وجدنا ان الابتسامه
مالغري شوف نشوفوا اللباس ولكن الابتسامه
دائما هذه عمليه بناء بعض المدارس
والهك لو استدعي مثلا واحد يربح في
السانكيام ولا يربح في البيام ولا يربح في
الباك سنقدم له ايباد نقدم لهم لاب تووب
سنقدم لهم يفرح ولكن وجدنا هناك اطفال
يفرحون بحبه حلوى ف طوابير طويله جدا من
اجل الحصول على حبه حلوى فقط هناك دور
الايتام ايضا دائما دائما تحتاج الى دعم
لماذا س اذا كانت في فرصه اخرى سنشرح
لماذا ينتشر الايتام بكثره في افريقيا
ولكم ان تبحثوا عن الاسباب حفر الابار حفر
الابار في 2016 ابار كثيره حفرناها والحمد
لله مشاريع استثماريه صغيره نجد مثلا بعض
الفقراء لا يستطيع ان فنشتري مثلا له اله
صناعه الطوب القالب هذاك من اجل ان يعمل
ويصبح غني بعد فتره الات الخياطه للنساء
اللواتي لديهن منحه خياطه الى اخره وهناك
قصص قصص كثيره جدا نامل ان تتاح لنا فرصه
اخرى من اجل حكايتها ايضا من الاشياء
الجميله ان يذهب مع اطباء زملائي الاطباء
لاعرفه صديق لماذا قوله لماذا لا تتطوع
الشيخ شويه في افريقيا فقول يلا نروحوا
فوجدنا تطوعنا في داخل دور الايتام وتطوع
في المستشفيات في المدارس حتى في الشارع
اذا عالم بانك طبيب يوقفك من فضلك شوف لي
وليدي ولا شوف لي بنتي وبالفعل
فهناك فحوصات طبيه او بعض الاحيان عمليات
جراحيه نقوم بها في المستشفيات او في في
اوغندا في مدينه تسمى ببوجي وصلنا الى
مستشفى وقمنا بفحوصات طبيه واتى
الينا مدير المستشفى يقول اول مره ارى
طبيب عربي يدخل هذا المستشفى والحمد لله
كان
جزائري ايضا بعد
العمليه طبعا لابد من فحصه بعد شراء
الادويه الى اخره وايضا وهو المفيد ايضا
ان نقدم محاضرات اداعيه صحيه لانه لا يكفي
الوقت دائما اعطيه الادويه واتي اليه
يعالجه لكن لابد من قايه قبل العلاج عبر
الاذاعات فاستغل الاذاعات لنقدم حصص
اذاعيه في مواضيع ملاريا مواضيع مثلا الى
اخره بالودي الى اخره من المواضيع اذا
فحوصات طبيه التكلف تكفل المسف العلاج
تكاليف العمليه الجراحيه شراء الادويه
وتوزيع بعض الاجهزه الطبيه مثل قياس السكر
قياس لا تونسيون الى اخره من هنا اقول
بانه اي مشروع لو نبقى انا اقول هذه
الكلمه لي واقولها لكم باننا لو دائما
نحضر مثل تدكس هذه ومثل البرامج التحفيزيه
دائما ونسمع الالاف من الساعات في
اليوتيوب اذا لم يتحرك شيء داخلنا باننا
نستطيع ان نغير فلن نستطيع ان نغير وقبل
ان
اذهب اريد تعرفت على صديق وهو ادم اريد ان
اقدم له لاني امل ان يعود بعد خمس سنوات
ست سنوات ليقف هنا في تدكس اقدم
له
قدم له عمله من دوله رواندا ليحتفظ بها
ولتعود ان شاء الله الى التكس
شكرا شكرا
لكم